Are infrared or near infrared sodas good for cancer?
Yes, yes they are. Well, let's take a step back.
So the infrared and near infrared sodas really are just sources of heat. So a true infrared unit
will not show any color because it's below the red spectrum.
So honestly, a true infrared unit that's, you know, that's producing infrared
is about, like our infrared hyperthermia unit is only like six inches by five inches and those
things are like five grain, okay? So do you think that you're getting true infrared? I don't care
what their brochure says from the panel that heats up. No, you are not. Plus true infrared
heats deep in the tissue. It doesn't really have surface heat. So a true infrared or an
infrared sauna or near infrared sauna, right? Honestly, you're not really getting any of the benefits
no matter what the company says from infrared radiation. That's just out there. So just
cross out of it. So let's just say sodas are sodas good for cancer? The answer is yes. And the reason
is is because you're sweating and when you're sweating, you're helping detoxify through your skin
and you're taking pressure off your liver and your kidneys. That's why it's good. We really want
infrared. You have to get a hyperthermia unit. It has to be skin-to-skin contact. It has to be
about six inches away from your skin. And it's only going to treat a very small area at one time.